dans un instant et on a voulu encore lui
rendre hommage au père lui rendre
hommage le faire un petit clin d'oeil
puisque les chroniqueurs nous ont fait
un petit sav des émissions regardées de
l'ump service après-vente tmp bonjour
bonjour ce week-end j'ai regardé big
bang sur tf1 c'est pas censé être une
émission autour bondi oui pourquoi pas
je me disais ce serait bien que
l'audience rebondissent aussi service
après-vente et pmp bonjour oui bonjour
j'ai vu que dans tpm paix il y avait des
régalade pour les gens qui regardent
oui c'est vrai on pourrait en faire pour
les chroniqueurs par exemple très bonne
idée
avec des augmentations par hasard alors
attendez excusez moi monsieur hanouna
m'a laissé une consigne à lire dans ce
cas là oui à léo faire cuire le cul band
par pas d'accord basse est bien due à
nouna ya pas de doute service a vraiment
de tmp bonjour bonjour j'ai vu que
francesca avait fait la star ac
et oui alors c'est pour ça qu'elle veut
absolument chanter dans le micro de
l'ormeau non
service après-vente de tpm t
bonjourbonjour hier j'ai regardé
questions pour un champion et je pense
que castaldi aurait des chances de
gagner
ah oui pourquoi parce que quand on
regarde la liste de ces mariages c'est
le seul qui arrive à faire un 4 à la
suite c'est pas fou ce service
après-vente tpm paix bonjour bah alors
on ne voit plus aux soirées non j'ai pas
le temps on a fait une soirée
boulangerie à la non non ça va et ont
montré leur grosse baguette c'est ça ah
non pas du tout on a juste manger des
croissants ma pardon et après on a
fouillé la rieuse ah non non non non non
service après-vente de dpe bonjour
espaces jil me suis déguisé en isabelle
morini bosc pour le faire une surprise
et alors tu allais chez elle à la mort
vers la porte il a cru que j'étais sa
femme il s'est jeté sur moi et il m'a
fait pas d'un quota d'eau soit en plus
revoir vers la beauté la rue bayard et
j'aime mieux un jacquouille je vous
regardez dans sous le soleil déjà vous
étiez si il était dense où ça a été
fabuleux